Susan Sarandon is 69 years old and sexy  as ever  the actress flaunts her cleavage in a  new ad for Marc Jacobs the designer  posted the seductive image shot by  photographer David Simms on Instagram  Tuesday he explains it was inspired by  Susan's role in the 1975 cult classic  The Rocky Horror Picture Show  Marc writes quote there's an inherent  seductive quality in Susan as a woman  who always speaks her mind and as an  artist who takes risks her talent as an  actress is one of extraordinary range  talent and power but it's not the first  time Susan's cleavage has been on full  display back in May she ran into selma  hayek at the cannes film festival this  is amazing and Salma shared a hilarious  photo on Instagram showing the ladies  comparing their chests side-by-side